here with reaction Fox News contributors
Ari Fleischer kellyanne Conway all right
let's start with you tonight let's get
to the bottom of of Kamala and Joe and
cocaine and sorry they didn't interview
a single person really
yeah but Sean on this one I'm going to
defend the Secret Service I won't defend
the Biden White House the secret
service's job is to protect the
president of the United States they are
not the Drug Enforcement Administration
their job is not to search for drugs it
is other okay then bring in the FBI the
Secret Service says there's no threat to
the president
but Joe Biden needs to
needs to do
that's what Joe Biden and his chief of
staff need to do this Secret Service
reaches decision that there's no threat
to the president at that point either
the White House wants to sweep it under
the rug or do something about it and
they do not take it seriously they're
happy to sweep it under the rug not the
Secret Service but Joe Biden and His
White House this is a political issue
for Joe Biden it's a leadership issue
and it's a failure to protect the White
House by Joe Biden his chief of staff
job there's no way that I ever see
kellyanne Conway ever Joe Biden uh
asking law enforcement to get to the
bottom of this 10 days no interviews
they have videotape of every single
person that went in that door everyone
and they could have easily interviewed
all of those people that was not an
investigation that was a cover-up
it was hardly even interrogation I mean
the crime here is worse than the
cover-up but the cover-up's pretty bad
Ari and I walked through that West exec
entrance probably thousands of times in
our respective White House careers and
we know where those lockers are we know
everything in the complex Sean and Ari
24 7 on camera I don't think it's that
difficult to narrow the circle who were
in that area not The West Wing uh in
that area it could have been somebody on
the tour it could have anybody the fact
is that you don't close something this
vital to the National interest in the
West Wing to Ari's Point close to where
the president works and lives within 10
days why we look for Russia occlusion
for three years we couldn't spend three
months on an investigation and and by
the way 193 kids under the age of five
have died of accidental fentanyl
poisoning recently why because tiny
little greens are left around
unbeknownst to them this could hurt
somebody this is this is an illicit Drug
In The West Wing and it should be taken
more seriously but Sean what if it was
dime of cocaine
okay to my house
by the way we don't even know that hey
Sean great Point why don't we at least
hear from them we tested the cocaine
here's what we want you to know about it
we don't know even anything about the
substance but you know why this is an
Administration that suffers from nothing
to see here everything is a distraction
Cornell West RFK Jr Donald Trump cocaine
in the White House Hunters legal
problems they want everything to go away
never to talk about it again I think
these guys pose a real threat to Joe
Biden's they're an accidental threat to
his candidacy and his presidency because
they're they are taken away from him in
these polls and they're letting Trump
beat him in the swing States according
to Echelon insights by eight points all
right thank you both Ari good to see you
and uh kellyanne good to see you hey
Sean Hannity here hey click here to
subscribe to Fox News YouTube page and
catch our hottest interviews and most
compelling analysis you will not get it
anywhere else